[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]
Valuraha is a [INAUDIBLE]
word for smart money.
And what we do at Valuraha,
we organize and connect you
to Africa's investment options.
We have a virtual
platform where we map out
all securities in the financial
markets-- shares, bonds,
T-bills, the works.
And we give you an opportunity
to create virtual portfolios.
To actually interact
with the actual markets
in using virtual money in
a bid to get you learning
and confident about the markets
so that you actually go out
and invest in real life.
It actually begun
from a point of need,
where my co-founders
and I realized
that despite our interest
in finance and in investing,
we don't really have
that much knowledge.
So even the little
investment we'd already done
wasn't as informed
as it could be.
And we found out that this was
one of the major reasons that
keeps people away from
the financial markets.
Because a lot of Kenyans
are heavily invested
in land and farming and
anything safer and much more
tangible, when actually
if you understood
the financial markets base you
can take advantage of a lot.
You can really grow
your money further.
We begun building as
soon as the platform was
minimally functional.
We ran a pilot with a few
finance students-- 10 of them
actually.
And we'd meet with them weekly
to talk about the platform.
And then widespread.
So our first users were
actually finance students
from Strathmore
School of Finance.
We envision that
we will be the go
to place for information
about investments
not just in Kenya but
about Africa as a whole.
And not just traditional
investment options like shares,
but we want to keep
up with the times
and go Bitcoin and go gold.
And just be that one place
where you come to be empowered.